Hello Freak bitches.
There's nothing reason to going on right
here.
There's no reasonable consideration of
the pros and cons of this issue.
And no one's,
there's no one's stepping in the middle,
right?
It's like the FBI and apple dispute.
That's what it's like.
It's the same thing.
You got it all on one side.
You've got all on the other.
And the reality is,
you know what,
we could have found a solution here
somewhere if,
uh,
you know,
if,
if we'd been added on,
I,
although who knows,
I don't know.
Apple seems to be inclined to draw a
line under this protection
killer issue.
Issue is they're trying to get into that
guy's phone.
The killer who killed those people in
San Bernandino.
They want to get into his phone and uh,
the FBI wants apple to engineer some
sort of a back door.
Well,
here's,
here's what it is.
So this guy,
uh,
side for had,
he had,
uh,
three phones,
at least that we know about,
two of them,
he destroyed.
He completely destroyed him.
And,
and the,
the,
the bureau's been looking,
they did nothing recoverable off those
systems.
And they've asked a lot of people for
assistance.
So they had the other phone,
which was in his truck,
which is his work phone.
It was belonged to the county.
And so they went to the county bureau,
did they went to the county when they
pulled his phone out of the truck and
they said,
we need to get the information off of
this thing because you know what,
a phone,
a phone nowadays everybody keeps
everything on their phone.
Right.
And so they uh,
they got the support they pulled and
they found out that he had shut off the
function that a uploads data to the
cloud,
uh,
in October.
And so they were able to get everything
up to October,
but then that's two full months prior to
the attack.
So they said,
okay,
well we can't get this and that.
And the,
the,
the phone has,
you know,
this default position where if you try
the password 10 times in a racist,
everything.
So they took the phone,
the bureau took the f,
the phone to apple and this was well
before they had to go and get a court
order.
Well before it became public knowledge,
they actually went and had numerous
quiet conversations with apple and they
went to apple and they said,
literally set,
you can take the phone,
keep it on your campus,
keep it in your facility,
put it,
no,
we don't.
You know,
wherever put in your lab,
all we're asking is for you to create a
systems information file that you can
force on that phone,
that one phone and pull the tech,
which then allows you to brute force the
password,
right?
And get the texts off of there,
get the data off of there and exists.
And then you can destroy the sif,
the systems information file.
You can keep the phone,
we don't even need to touch it.
We,
you know,
whatever you just give us the shit
that's on the phone.
An apple has,
has been helpful in the past.
They've been,
they've been helpful in the past and
this time for some,
for whatever motivation they've decided
to draw a line in the sand and say,
no,
we're not going to do this.
And it's not as if they haven't been
helpful.
And there's an ongoing dialogue.
And so it's,
it's disingenuous to say that apple is
now,
you know,
uh,
the bulwark for privacy because they
have been in the past and they will
continue to be helpful,
I suppose in their own way.
But for this particular phone,
for this one time where they could have
held onto the phone,
created that Sif destroyed the sif at,
at that moment that they've pulled the
texts officer,
that's it.
That's done.
So now what Tim Cook is saying is not
that it's creating a backdoor.
He's not saying that he's saying it
creates a precedent,
but the precedent was already that if
the bureau goes through the,
the,
the process the congress has set and
then goes through that process and gets
a court order and the court,
then it looks at it and says,
yes,
you've got probable cause you've got
reasonable concern here.
Uh,
they provide a court order,
then they go and they make this request
for assistance.
They're also talking about a dead guy
talking about a guy who shot 14 paper
was killed,
14 people.
Um,
I've heard all sorts of things.
I've heard people say to me,
and I,
and again,
I understand,
don't get me wrong,
because I understand fully the
importance of finding the right place on
the pendulum for Security and privacy.
I get that.
And that's an important discussion.
I'm not saying it's not,
it's,
you should always have that
conversation,
but part of that is then during the
course of that conversation,
Congress,
the courts,
they make those decisions.
Where does that pendulum,
you know,
settle between security and privacy?
And that settles here.
Okay,
fine.
Then that's what the bureau or whomever
has to go through to get approval to get
some assistance.
And that's where it stands.
But you know,
to say that because now you've got all
three branches of government have said,
yeah,
we think that really we could use this
information off of this phone.
But I've heard everybody say,
well,
why don't they just do the rest of the
investigation?
Well,
of course they fucking done the rest of
the investigation.
They don't all the other investigative
steps.
So what are you're saying in a situation
like this?
Uh,
you just want them to do 80% of the
investigation.
And if you've got,
you know,
that you've got material on here who,
which may lead to operational activity,
uh,
in,
in finding other people who were
involved or finding people overseas who
were in somehow assisting or whatever it
may be.
If you're saying,
well,
just know,
you know what,
for the sake of this,
we're not asking for a back door.
They're asking for that.
So that,
that one phone,
and that's where this whole thing is
really headed south and it's become this
idea that,
you know,
which is erroneous.
But I understand what Tim Cook is saying
about the precedent,
although not really,
because again,
they've done this before.
For some reason for this one,
they're drawing a line.
So anyway,
I,
but I've heard that,
why don't they just do the rest of the
investigation and skip this part?
What I don't,
I don't,
I don't follow that logic train.
And then the other people,
other people were saying,
well,
why don't they just get it off the
metadata?
And that's another one of those things
where people never believed what the
government was saying,
but the metal fucking data was numbers
and volume.
That was it.
There was no information to be had
there.
You could sit in a fucking room full of
metadata and not know what the hell
you're looking at.
You had to go through the court process
to then get that particular numbers,
uh,
information.
So here's my question,
because this is what came up with the
Edward Snowden thing.
They were saying that the government is
monitoring all cell phone data
constantly and they can get information
all the time.
Well,
this kind of proves that not to be true.
Yeah.
But people don't look at it that way.
They don't,
they don't,
they don't make that leap back and say,
oh,
well maybe that was a fallacy.
Yeah,
sure.
The metadata was sweeping up all that,
that those numbers and volume.
But again,
it's not enough to what end.
Yeah.
And so some people would say,
once they realize what it was actually
doing,
then they say,
wow,
but that's so what?
So they're just collecting this shit in
the basement.
It's not doing any good.
So they shouldn't even collect that
information.
So what Edward Snowden was talking about
is essentially just when it pertains to
email,
I mean,
he said they're collecting all this
information that the NSA is collecting
all this information in regards to cell
phone data,
the recording,
every phone call,
all these text messages.
Yeah.
Um,
so is that not true?
Well,
no,
I frankly,
I'm here.
Of course nobody's going to,
again,
this is a very emotive,
right?
So there's all these people out there,
they're going to say,
fuck you.
You don't know what the fuck are you
talking about?
Yeah,
no,
there is nobody right now unless you're
a terrorist,
a terrorist suspect or a criminal.
This,
nobody in the government hooks up fuck
about you.
I'm here to tell you your Dick pics or
safe ladies and Gentlemen,
Dick Pics are absolutely safe.
Jina pictures that you've been floating
around telling your boyfriend or,
okay girls,
it's secure.
Nobody's going to route those around
that.
And are you out for those as a piece of
shit and UNAMERICAN in the first place?
Yeah.
So that's a,
that's a really eyeopening thing though
because this case kind of throws that
all into jeopardy cause everybody was
like concerned.
Like,
Hey,
the government can check in on all your
phone calls and all your text messages.
Well this would clearly be a case where
they would want to do that so that they
don't,
if they can't do it here without the,
did the judge granting this order and
what,
so tell me why did,
there was a recent court order there
ruled in favor of apple.
They did.
And that was in New York and that was an
interesting case as well.
And that's probably going to set a
precedent for maybe,
maybe we'll see cause it's a little bit
different what the judge essentially was
saying in that case and it involved,
uh,
narco trafficking investigation that was
going on.
And by the way,
this isn't just for terrorism.
Imagine what if this was for Pete
Ophelia,
I mean,
I imagine a large Pete Ophelia ring.
What are you going to say?
No,
we don't want to catch those fucking
Douche bags that are involved in that
because privacy,
you know,
I understand the privacy aspect,
but each case has to be looked at on its
merits.
And if you say through the courts and
through the,
through the congress that these are the
hoops that the bureau has to jump
through and they jumped through those
hoops,
then then what?
Then it's up to each company to decide
where they want to support it or not.
I don't know that,
that seems strange.
But anyway,
the point being is that the one in New
York,
the judge essentially was saying,
well look,
you want us,
you want the courts to make a decision
on this for something that Congress
should really make a decision on this.
And so he,
in a way,
his decision was a pushback against the
concept of the,
that the,
uh,
the bureau was basing this on,
which is a very old law.
And so the judge is saying,
look,
you're relying on a law that's a couple
of hundred years old or whatever.
Um,
maybe instead we should be having this
looked at it through the legislature.
And so there was a,
there was an interesting sort of
legality to his,
his response to this,
but it,
it definitely,
uh,
favorite apple and,
and,
and and sure.
That's great.
Let's legislate it.
But do you think that just maybe,
um,
there are times when from an operational
perspective,
you might want to move a little bit
quicker than asking Congress to take up,
uh,
an issue and debate it and then maybe
eventually come up.
So maybe occasionally you're going to
have moments like this,
the San Bernardino shooting where you've
got a phone in your hand and all you're
asking apple to do is take possession of
it.
And who knows?
Maybe their problem is they're worried
that if they create the sif at that
moment,
someone's going to steal it from them.
I met one of their employees,
so maybe they got an internal security
issue because then they can destroy it.
The bureau is not asking for that phone
back.
They're not asking for that Sif.
They're not asking them for to do it on
any other,
what is this?
Sif is a systems information file.
Okay.
So you just force it onto that phone and
that bypasses the capacity.
Essentially what the court has done is
made a very conservative,
conservative interpretation of the law.
Right.
And basically saying that this needs to
be,
this is a place with the courts should
be deciding,
we believe you should be taking this to
Congress.
And so therefore I don't see why you're
legislating or asking us to make a
decision on this.
You see,
I understand the common person's
perspective.
They don't trust the government,
the whole Edward Snowden leaks thing.
Everybody's freaking out about that.
And then they look at this saying,
well,
this is the slippery slope.
Again,
this is the thing that if the government
has access to your phone,
like we're talking about a fucking mass
murderer and a guy who's already dead
and we have one phone.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's,
and,
and so to say that you're going to only
do a limited investigation,
even though you know you've got
potential information,
right?
And your way to do it,
like on an individual basis,
just one phone only.
That's what they're asking for.
That's what they're asking.
But can it be that you could never grant
ag?
I mean it's,
it's,
it doesn't make any sense to me.
Well,
you wouldn't want to get access to that
guy's fucking data.
And here's where I think going back to
that overriding theme,
which is nothing resides in the center
anymore.
You're right.
We do have to be concerned about
privacy.
And I agree.
Okay,
what happens if you don't?
Big Brother.
But there are times when,
you know,
operational concerns probably override
a,
at least an element of this where you
have common pr or a reason to,
people can exist in the comment in the
middle and say,
yeah,
on this occasion,
because you've gone through all these,
these orders and because we've set up
this protection now,
meaning,
you know,
apple holds onto it and have it,
but you know,
it,
that's not the way it works.
And so therefore apple comes out and
says there,
and then the misinformation,
ah,
they're trying to create a backdoor to
our apple devices.
By the way,
what do you think apple does with their
devices that they sell in China?
Do you think the Chinese government
would allow apple if someone's got to
talk about this in the media,
do you think the Chinese government
would allow apple to sell devices that
they can't get into?
I,
uh,
we could ask.
Okay.